hey guys it's Johanna here it's at that
time of the year again you're heading
back to school and as students I do
understand you don't always have the
time to fit in a long workout session so
I've put together a really quick and
efficient eight minute workout which you
can do first thing in the morning or in
the evening before you end your day okay
so this workout is going to help boost
your metabolism and give you the focus
you need in school so before you head
into the shower
be sure to sweat it out let's do this so
each workout will be for 45 seconds with
15 seconds rest in between okay if you
want to push yourself then you can do
the entire workout for one minute
without any break so the first workout
will be a gentle and easy squat this
will also act as your warmup to really
loosen up and open up the hips and also
your back alright so Stesha sugar with a
pot toes pointed forward and we want to
go in five seconds keep your chest up
back straight and really push your butt
back okay let's go squat down push your
butt back and squat down alright every
time you squat you're opening a hips up
and I want you to really go low and push
back up with your heels nice gentle easy
squat if you're doing this in the
morning it's a really great way to
stretch out your entire body good so up
squeeze your butt and nice keep going
good all right if you want to challenge
yourself then by all means get into a
jump squat okay nice and easy up and
down it's a push-up with a huge good
squeeze your glutes squeeze those butt
muscles okay up chest up
do not fall and hunched over okay good
keep going
deep squat as low as you can and rest it
out second workout we want to work on
our upper body so it's going to be a
push-up with tap okay so get down onto
the mat right start with your aunt pumps
on the floor all right let's go into a
push up push up and gently tap nice one
and tap good avoid twisting your body
too much
and tap just nice gentle touch on your
shoulder good keep going keep your abs
tight core engaged and a nice deep
crucial and gentle tap very good if you
struggle with this by all means you can
go onto your toes keep going good well
you should feel your blood flowing in
your body by now good tap and few more
tap last two more tab and rest it out
let's get back up okay right now your
heart rate should be elevated slightly
so I want you to go into a lunge and
twist so stand in front of your mat okay
take a back step lunch up and twist okay
again it's all about opening up your
body your hips and really working on
your obliques good nice if you want to
challenge yourself get into a nice deep
hop really small gentle hop and twist
elbow to knee elbow to knee one more and
now let's change side so same thing
lunge and twist find your balance
look straight ahead and twist good
lunge back and twist want to challenge
yourself hop good hands up hop good
twist it out very nice twist few more
twists and rest it out next workout your
favorite workout burpees yes so we want
to really push your heart rate and bring
it high up okay this is going to work
your entire body you know burpees
let's go hop it out okay good so all the
way down give me full energy and hop it
up good again beginner if you struggle
remove the hop and just stand tall okay
stretch your entire body use this chance
to really give your body a good
elongated stretch nice keep going
halfway there whoa remember always pace
your breathing few more back and up ten
more seconds nice whoo you're with me
okay stay with me
do not stop right now and rest next
workout Mountain kinda still on your
cardio and we want to focus on your core
so get down onto the mat okay again arms
shoulder width apart palms wide okay
let's go strong mountain climber climb
it up okay
avoid hiking your butt high up okay this
is wrong back flat and nice deep
mountain climber bring your knee towards
your chest
whew this is not easy but it's going to
really work on your core your arm
strength and also your leg so it's all
about your breathing the better you pace
your breathing
the longer you will last through your
workout ten more seconds let's speed it
up bring it up stay with me keep your
back flat few more and rest it out next
leg kickbacks okay so I want you to sing
still maintain the same position let's
start with your right leg and your left
hand okay beginner you can't just use
your leg so bring your knee in kick your
back squeeze your butt okay really
elongate that and squeeze your butt
cheek all right if you want to combine
your arms bring it in extend elongate
extend okay so this workout it's also
about stretching and waking all those
muscles up it will also improve on your
flexibility good now let's switch side
extend in extend
in keep going Luke straight down okay
relax your neck relax her shoulders
squeeze your butt cheek right at the top
last one and rest
good job all right now let's lie flat
onto the mat okay lay cliffs to really
work on your lower abs all right so you
can place your arms just by your side
leg straight bring your legs up bring it
down and up and down so only bring it as
low as you can without arching your low
back beginners if this is half bend your
knee bring it up and down okay touch tap
the floor up and down as you progress
then you want to extend your leg
straight bring it up and down good job
keep going whoa really work on those
lower abs muscle nice up and down
strengthen those lower abs feel your
legs shaking it is good and and rest it
out all right
let's flip over let's get into a plank
okay so instead of a regular price I
want you to do plank in and out all
right so five seconds elbows and plank
out wider than the mat in okay out why
does that I met in remember do not Pike
up a kid this is wrong keep your back
flat and in so it's all about
controlling your core movement okay out
and in good out and in
nice I can see my sweat dripping on the
mat it's like raining and in good keep
going and in last workout stay with me
this is your last eight minute stay with
me few more and in
eight seconds laughs whoa my sweat is
dripping let me know how you're doing
well done oh my god it's only eight
minutes but look at me I am absolutely
drenched
it's dead okay so just what restaurant
off take your time and just stretch it
out okay get into a child's pose and
just stretch it out as you can see I am
drenched in sweat so remember it is not
about the length of the workout but
rather the intensity of a workout a shot
intense workout is even more effective
than a long low intense workout okay so
if you can do this workout on a daily
basis and you can even repeat this
entire workout three to four more times
and make it a full solid workout so be
sure to like this video share this
workout with your friends and get them
to join you all right subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos recipes and also fitness tips
every Monday Wednesday and Friday and
don't forget to also turn on the
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new video
all the best